[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good evening, everybody.
I'm Jennifer Roberts.
I'm the faculty
director for the arts
here at the Radcliffe Institute.
Welcome to you all.
And thank you all for coming.
It's great to see
so many people here
for our opening celebration
for our new exhibition
in the Johnson-Kulukundis
Gallery of the work of Anna Von
Mertens.
Now for those of
you who have not
attended an art opening
at Radcliffe before,
this is how it goes.
It's basically a
two venue event.
We'll be spending the next 45
to 50 minutes in this room.
Anna will be giving
a short presentation
about her exhibition and
its place in the history
of her larger body of work.
And then she and I will
have a quick conversation
with whatever time is
remaining after her talk.
Then we'll all get up and make
our way over to Byerly Hall
to see the exhibition, which
is just two buildings down.
And that will last
until around 7 o'clock.
All right.
So I first came across
Anna's work in 2006
in the fall 2006 issue of
Cabinet Magazine, which
featured two quilts from
her celebrated series titled
As the Stars Go By.
And these hand stitched works
trace the paths of stars
as they appear silently pivoting
over epic or disastrous events
in human history.
I had to squint to
make out the details
in the images in the magazine.
And for reasons that
will become clear
when you go over to the gallery
Anna's work really does not
reproduce easily or well.
So I had to squint to
make out these details.
But I was really transfixed
by the richness of her work,
particularly the
way it so rigorously
and also elegantly
collapsed a whole series
of seemingly essential,
seemingly eternal oppositions--
craft and computation,
science and domesticity,
affect and
indifference, closeness
and distance, body and mind.
I promptly sent her an email.
And this was the first
and only artist fan
letter I have ever written.
10, 11 years went by, stars
silently gliding overhead.
And I took on this position as
faculty director of the arts
at Radcliffe.
And I found myself charged
with the task of inviting
contemporary artists to show
work in our contemporary art
gallery.
This brought about
my second email
to Anna, which ultimately
brought about this exhibition.
Radcliffe's goal as
many of you know,
is to foster
intellectual engagement
across multiple different
fields and communities
within and beyond Harvard.
And I could think of
no one better suited
to make that kind
of connectivity
happen in our gallery than Anna.
As she developed
her exhibition, she
visited campus several times
in order to do research.
And she found herself
spending a lot of time
at the Harvard College
Observatory studying the women
computers so they were
called who analyzed the glass
plate astronomical photographs
there at around the turn
of the 20th century.
Anna will have much more to
say about all this in her talk.
But before welcoming
her to the podium,
I want to take a moment to
thank a few of the people
and the communities
that made this quite
complex exhibition possible.
Within Radcliffe I want to
thank Meg Rotzel and Joe
Zane of the Arts Program team,
the whole Academic Ventures
team--
particularly Sean
O'Donnell who has
organized the programming
and curricular
outreach for this exhibition--
the Dean's Office for its
support of the complexities
of this show.
I want to thank Alyssa Goodman,
who is Radcliffe Faculty
Director in Science
who also happens
to be an astronomer
who kindly advised us
on many such matters.
And any errors in that
department I must assure you
are our own.
We also had generous help and
consultation from the Harvard
University Archives,
the Harvard Smithsonian
Center for Astrophysics, and
the Harvard College Observatory.
Now an essential part
of this exhibition
is the book that accompanies it.
This is the book here.
You will see this
again in the gallery.
This is something
that started out
as an idea for a small brochure.
But it became much more
ambitious and beautiful
than it had any right to be.
And for that we are thankful
to Anna's dedication
to the publication,
to the editing
wizardry of Rachel Vogel
and Victoria Waters,
and to John Kramer--
our brilliant book designer.
There are several copies of
the book in the gallery for you
to look at when you enter
the space this evening.
We also have a limited number
of complimentary copies
for visitors to the exhibition.
So if you would like
to request a copy,
there will be cards
in the gallery
that you can pick
up with instructions
for signing up online to
get a copy of the book.
There will also be some for
sale at the Carpenter Center
Bookstore starting
I believe next week.
I also want to mention
that with this exhibition
we're experimenting at Radcliffe
with a new program called
the Gallery Series in which
we're inviting students,
faculty, and staff to respond
to the exhibition on view
in a series of events
in the gallery space
that will extend throughout the
entire range of the exhibition.
These events are organized
by Academic Ventures.
If you go to
onviewatradcliffe.org
you'll be able to see a list
of these events, which include
everything from displays of
the historic astronomical glass
plates to live performances
by Harvard musicians, dancers,
and vocalists.
All right.
So I know you're all
eager to hear from Anna.
And I'm equally eager
to introduce her.
Anna Von Mertens received
her Bachelor's Degree
in Visual Arts from Brown
University and her MFA
from the California
College of the Arts.
Her work is in
the collections of
and has been shown in
numerous exhibitions
throughout the United
States, including the MFA
Boston, the Berkeley Art Museum,
the Smithsonian American Art
Museum, the RISD Museum, the
Boston Center for the Arts,
Mills College Art Museum,
Ballroom Marfa, the deCordova
Sculpture Park and Museum
just down the street along
with many other collections.
She is the recipient of a Louis
Comfort Tiffany Foundation
Biennial Award and a
United States Artist
Fellowship in the Visual Arts.
We're very honored to have her
and her work here at Radcliffe.
It's been a really thrilling
and stimulating process
for me working with
Anna on this exhibition.
I and we have all learned
a great deal already.
For example, I know a
lot more about quilting
than I ever did before.
But I also happen to know
about the period luminosity
relation in variable stars now.
Anna will enlighten you about
this as well I understand.
Please join me in welcoming her.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hi, thank you, Jennifer,
for that introduction.
And thank you, Jennifer, really
for being as excited as I
have been about this project.
So that has been such a joy to
work with you this past year.
And thank you to the
folks at the Radcliffe
and at the Observatory in
support of this project.
So this story has many
beginnings like all stories do.
And I've chosen this beginning,
because when Jennifer invited
me to do an exhibition
here at the Radcliffe,
because my work
is research based
she offered to tour the
various archives on campus
and see some of the collections
in the various libraries,
all of which were remarkable.
But when we got here to the
Harvard College Observatory
I knew we needed to look no
further, because housed here
are over 500,000 glass plate
photographs of the night sky.
And these photographs were
taken started in the 1880s all
the way through the 1990s.
And they were taken at
observation stations set up
by Harvard around
the globe in both
the northern and
southern hemispheres.
And this is the oldest and
most comprehensive record
of the night sky on the planet.
And so Jennifer and I got to
see some of these glass plates
on our first visit there.
And most of the
plates look like this.
They are negatives.
And they are made by coating
a plate of glass and emulsion,
exposing that plate of glass
to starlight through telescope.
And each star registers
as a tiny black dot.
This was a new kind of
technology-- this dry plate
photography.
And with this new technology
came an enormous influx
of data to be analyzed.
And Edward Pickering, the man
shown here in this photograph,
was the director of the
observatory at the time
that this new technology
was developed.
And he was progressive
but also practical.
And he realized that
if he hired women
in the role of
analyzing these glass
plates that they were a
cheaper labor force than men.
And so that's what he did during
his more than 40 year tenure
as director.
He hired over 80
women in this job.
And their task was to ascertain
the brightness of the stars,
as well as their color
spectra, because at the time
the sky was an
unmapped territory.
Very little was known
about the composition
of the stars and the
relationship to one another.
So they set about this task.
And Henrietta Leavitt, who is
the subject of my exhibition,
is one of the Harvard computers.
And as Jennifer
mentioned, they are
known as computers--
the Harvard computers.
And she was one of these women.
And she excelled at
the stellar magnitude
work, which sounds so simple to
gauge the brightness of a star.
But you saw how tiny those
specks were in those plates.
And so simply locating a
star on one of those plates
and comparing one star to
another on a single plate
is a task enough.
But the results varied
from plate to plate.
Different telescopes
produced different results.
Even the viewing conditions,
of course, were different.
But even the color of the
temperature of starlight
affected that emulsion
in divergent ways.
So to make a single
determination
you had to assimilate all
these sort of little bits
of information and
form a hold-- hold
those pieces of
information in your mind
to make a single
determination much
less that same determination
for hundreds and thousands
of stars.
And the women often worked in
this way taking a glass plate.
And the emulsion was on
one side of the plate.
And on the other side
they could mark in ink
some notations if
they were following
a certain sequence of interest
or noting certain stars.
And here you see markings from
several different computers.
This sequence-- this photograph
taken by Jennifer Roberts--
this lower letter sequence
here is typical of the research
methods of Henrietta Leavitt.
And you can see here
in another example
of one of those plates
another lettered sequence.
And here you note that one
of the stars is marked VAR.
It's short for variable star.
And as part of this
stellar magnitude work
these variable stars
were identified.
And variable stars are stars
that pulse from bright to dim
and bright again over
varying expanses of time.
So I won't go into
the intricacies
of how they located--
imagine one of those specks
over a random period of time
changing in size and
then reducing again--
I won't go into the intricacies
of how they determined
these variable stars.
But rest assured
it was intricate.
Here's an example of
the impeccable pages
of Henrietta Levitt's logbooks.
I think they're beautiful.
And they're compositions
on their own.
And you can see here alongside
the columns of her magnitude
work she often would sketch
these sequences of the stars
with these little
pencil drawings.
And here you can see
that she's located
another new variable star.
And just as Henrietta Leavitt
excelled at the stellar
magnitude work, she
was an all-star--
terrible pun.
I was like, promised myself
I wasn't going to say that.
She was an all-star at
identifying variable stars.
And so here's her paper
in 1908 publishing
an almost ridiculous amount of
1,777 variable stars located
in the Magellanic Clouds alone.
And Henrietta Leavitt identified
more than 2,400 variable stars
in her lifetime, which
was more than half
of all known variable
stars at the time.
So you know, those numbers
just speak for themselves.
And in this 1908 paper
she has a simple sentence
that it is worthy of notice
that the brighter the star,
the longer it takes
for a star to pulse
and the dimmer a star, the
shorter period of time.
And I love that she
used the word notice,
because notice I
think is considered
a sort of passive action, right?
It's almost something that
you sort of come across.
And you realize here what
an active, powerful action
noticing actually is.
And then I just want to-- two
sentences down I just want
to read this--
I love this sentence.
Like, all right.
I'm just going to read it.
"This is especially striking in
the case of number 821, which
has a period of 127
days as 89 observations
with 45 returns of maximum
give an average deviation
from the light curve of
only 6/100 of a magnitude."
So that's just a
ridiculous sentence, right?
That's--
[LAUGHTER]
--going into a
single variable star.
So just again multiply
these calculations
and these observations
again and again and again.
So she notices
this relationship.
And she follows up
in 1912 her findings
that indeed the length of how
long a star takes to pulse
is indeed directly linked
to how bright that star is.
And she graphs
this relationship.
And a smooth logarithmic
curve is produced.
Astronomers
immediately knew this
had enormous ramifications,
because now you could just
look at a variable star, see
how long it took to pulse,
and plug that into the
curve and determine
how bright that star should be.
And I like that
you're like, I thought
I came to an art lecture.
No, this is just astronomy.
We're going to--
I will get to the
art eventually.
OK.
So how bright that
star should be
and then if that star is not
as bright as it should be,
astronomers could calculate
the amount of distance
causing that light to dim.
So now astronomers had a
distance ladder to the stars.
They could tell how
far away stars were.
And this was immediately put
to use determining the size
and shape of our Milky Way.
And then Edwin Hubble
locating a variable star
in the Andromeda
Nebula as it was
called at the time determined
that that variable star
and therefore Andromeda was
so far outside the scope--
I mean so far away, that it was
outside the scope of our Milky
Way Galaxy--
therefore, putting to rest the
debate whether our galaxy was
the extent of our universe as
many people thought at the time
or if there were these
island galaxies beyond.
And so these galaxies
were identified beyond us.
And then Edwin Hubble
went even farther
not only identifying
these galaxies.
But the farther away galaxies
were from us, the faster
they were moving away from us.
So he's proving that--
or demonstrating
that the universe is expanding.
So all of these
discoveries sort of
tumbled forth in a 15
year period of time
from Leavitt's findings.
The tragic part of this
story is that Levitt
died of cancer just as these
findings were coming to light.
So finding out about the life
and work of Henrietta Leavitt
I was inspired to make a kind of
tribute to that life and work.
And I've decided
to show the stars
on the morning of her birth
above the place of her birth
and then the stars
again on her death
above the place of her death.
And I did this by using
star calculation software.
I could type in the
latitude and longitude,
type in the time and
date, and see the stars--
a kind of time traveling
to that place in time--
see the stars that
were seen on that night
and project them onto fabric.
I traced each star
with chalk and then
assigned my own
magnitudes system.
I assigned a numeric value based
on how bright that star was.
And then playing time
forward on my computer
I would trace that path
of light with chalk,
go back to my computer,
restart the time,
play time forward, trace
another path of light
and so again and again and again
until I had this trajectory
of the stars across the sky.
And then taking
my numeric system
I corresponded that
to thread color.
So depending on
how bright the star
was it got a color
through the grayscale.
And then I wanted to show a
several hour passage of time
the stars on that morning
as the light faded
from you with the rising of
the sun and then on the evening
the brightest stars
first returning into view
and the light--
starlight returning
the view as the sunset on
the evening of her death.
So with each star I would
take its original thread color
depending on its brightness
and then change thread color
every couple of
inches as I sewed
so that each line
path of light faded
into the black background.
And what you got is this sort
of curtain of light pulled back.
And what is held in
between, of course,
is the span of Henrietta
Leavitt's life.
I also joked with myself that
is also a pole in my studio
is what's held in between.
But luckily in the gallery
there are no poles.
[LAUGHTER]
So here's this space in between.
And with this exhibition I want
to ask the question of what
meaning is held in a
single life and then
what meaning do we
hold collectively.
And echoed in that question is
another question-- what meaning
is held in a single action?
And what meaning is built with
the repetition of that action,
because Henrietta Leavitt
repeated many actions--
observations and calculations
again and again and again.
And certainly in
my own practice,
I repeat actions
of the sewn stitch
and the mark made again
and again and again.
And we all repeat actions
in our daily lives
that we hope builds into
a cumulative meaning,
whether we're building a home,
a community, a discovery,
a work of art.
But what remains in
that single action?
So as Jennifer said I'm
thrilled that this story can
be told in richer detail
through the publication
that we produced.
I'm so grateful to the
Radcliffe Institute
and for the folks
here that supported
the making of this book.
It includes writings
by myself and an essay
by Jennifer Roberts and a
beautiful, beautiful, beautiful
book designed by John Kramer.
So that is one
beginning to this story.
I'm going to go back
in time a little bit
and talk about
another beginning.
And in that, I always knew
I wanted to be an artist.
But it wasn't until I made
a simple patchwork quilt
that I realized I wanted the
quilts to be the medium that I
put my ideas into.
And that is because quilts
have such rich contexts--
associations with
the bed and intimacy
and the home and the body and
of history and women's work.
But it wasn't until I
thought about moving blankets
that this idea solidified,
because moving blankets
are also quilts.
They are three
layers sewn together.
But instead of
solidifying the home,
they speak about a
home in transition.
They-- protecting an
object in transition.
And so with that,
I started thinking
about navigating this
space between the familiar
and the unfamiliar, the
known and the unknown.
And my work centered there--
started to revolve
around themes of mapping,
defining this territory,
defining the space.
So the first piece I made
using quilt as my medium
was the logical starting
point-- self portrait.
And in it I made a map of my
own body-- a topographical map.
And by getting
underneath the fabric
and using a laser leveler and my
beloved husband sitting there--
patient husband-- in shock
followed that beam of light
around my body, lowered
the laser leveler,
and followed it a quarter
inch again and again
and again until we had a
topographic map of my body.
If we had known how long
this would have taken,
I would have chosen a much
more comfortable position,
because it was like hours later.
So I had this chalk pattern.
I then sewed it.
Here's a detail of the
topographic map of my head
and my nose as the high point.
And here's a detail
of my shoulder
with my arm across my chest.
And the red square
references both a girl
getting our period for the
first time and the acute sort
of awareness that accompanies
that rite of passage
as well as in several
traditional cultures
a bride needing to show
the nuptial sheets to prove
her virginity.
So I was playing with these
public and private spheres--
this idea of revealing
versus concealing,
of exposing versus comforting
using those associations
of the quilt, of the bed.
Here in this
installation each quilt
has a map in its stitch
pattern of some sort.
And it's-- that map is
oriented towards north.
And I want to cite--
I deliberately chose
showing these quilts
in the form of the
bed as bed sculptures
citing the work in the
space of the everyday--
the space that we
existed in and walk in.
Here's another piece
sort of speaking
to these public and private
spheres coming together--
here talking about subjective
and objective versions
of color.
On the left hardware
store paint chips--
an industrial kind
of color that I then
hand dye so already activating
that relationship between so
the personal and the commercial.
But then on the right, making
my own systems for color
and determining my
own personal paint
chips that I also hand dyed.
And the stitch pattern
speaks to this relationship.
There are two different patterns
of the same circuit board.
So the circuitry is
different on each piece.
But the vias, which are plated
holes allowing information
to pass from one layer of the
circuit board to another--
those are the same
pattern on each piece.
So I'm talking about where there
are those areas of connection,
where there's these
possibilities for communication
and understanding, and where
these layers are separate.
And the final bed sculpture
I'll touch on tonight--
the forefront
sculpture is dealing
with my personal relationship
with the American landscape.
But the piece in back is--s
I wanted to show is the first
moving blanket sort
of I ever made--
my version of a moving blanket.
And because moving blankets you
know have that parallel line
zigzag--
that's their stitch pattern.
So here I have parallel
lines hand stitched.
But at the northern border
of the United States
it shifts 90 degrees.
And then at the southern
border of the United States
it shifts 90 degrees again.
And this was a political context
for the American identity
the American landscape.
And what's interesting
is that this piece
gets activated, because
it is seen as a sculpture.
When you walk around
the piece the parallel
lines inside the United States
get surfaced on one direction.
But when you walk
around to the other side
the parallel lines in the
other direction surface.
And the lines within
the United States sink.
So as you walk around there's
this sort of pulsing--
again, terrible puns tonight--
variable star sort of but
this pulsing that happens--
this sort of
sinister omnipresence
of the United States,
this piece made in 2003
at the beginning of the
second war with Iraq.
So that climate
was very present.
And then I moved to the wall.
I had enjoyed this using
the associations of the bed.
But I started to feel
limited by that scope.
And I started thinking
about the wall
and realized that my
work belonged on the wall
as soon as I engaged
in the act of looking.
I started to think about the
wall as sort of in opposition
to the viewer, not
necessarily a confrontation
but simply a surface that
we engaging that action
of looking.
And if I engage that act, the
works belonged on the wall.
And to me the most age old
form of looking is star gazing.
It's a way that we look out
into the heavens to sort
of more specifically
register physically
and internally where we are.
And this is the
series that Jennifer
referenced in her introduction
As the Stars Go By.
And it is the first time I used
the star calculation software.
And it shows as Jennifer
mentioned the stars
above violent moments
in American history.
So here are the stars that
Christopher Columbus first
saw in 1492 when he
first sighted land up
to current events
such as the beginning
of the second war
with Iraq where bombs
were falling over Baghdad.
And you see the
constellation of Scorpio
tracking across the sky.
And I wanted to set up that
really specific act of viewing.
So each piece has
the aspect ratio
of a movie screen encompassing
an individual scope of vision
so again really
calling into question--
very specifically locating
the viewer at a vantage point,
and then calling into
question whether this
was an active or passive role,
if the viewer was complicit
or a bystander in these events.
Another event chosen--
the Tet Offensive
during the Vietnam War.
And all these events were
chosen as pivot points--
sort of where what came before
is separate from what follows.
So here as the
American psyche shifted
during the Tet
Offensive-- this moment
in time being demonstrated.
And the final event
I'll touch on--
the assassination of
Martin Luther King--
so these are the stars seen
from the balcony of the Lorraine
Motel in the direction
the shots are fired--
that hour span of time
between when Martin Luther
King was shot and an hour later
when he was pronounced dead.
And these events are--
these works are certainly
intended as a memorial
to these pieces, as a
awareness of these events.
But there also was this
strange, cold comfort
in this natural cycle continuing
despite the violence below.
So as Jennifer said this was
her introduction to my work
and so yet another beginning
to this story and the final one
I'll touch on tonight.
And I don't know if
Jennifer specified.
But she did send
me that fan mail.
And I did reply back
saying, thank you very much.
But I love that it
was that same email
chain that she
responded to 10 years
later when she invited me--
[LAUGHTER]
--here to the Radcliffe.
So to me that's like
another bridge of time
that this exhibition connects.
So fast forward 10 years
I made a lot of work
in between that didn't have
anything do with the stars.
But at the time that
Jennifer contacted me
I was fascinated again
with the heavens.
And I had just finished
this body of work,
which was based on a new
structure in the universe--
the largest known
structure of the cosmos--
that as a new
contemporary finding.
And cosmologists realized
that if you subtract
the expansion of the
universe, what is revealed
is this kind of
cosmic watershed.
You can see how galaxies
cluster with each other.
So certain-- towards these
basins of attraction--
so there's these pull as these
galaxies flow towards one basin
and diverge away to another one.
So what gets defined is
this gravitational boundary
of our galaxy super cluster.
And keep in mind this
super cluster includes
100,000 galaxies-- so
just a incomprehensible
sort of ocean of space.
But this gravitational
boundary is
defined of what
galaxies float together
towards a central
basin of attraction
versus a neighboring
super cluster--
a very close neighbor
that diverges away.
And what interested
me as an artist
is that you could take
this model and sort of play
with it as if you might
sculpt clay and look
at these rotated views.
So this is just
the same structure.
But seen from a
different point of view.
And I, of course, get lost
in the mountain of data
that goes into this finding.
So what I did was return
to a very elemental form
of drawing-- the
gesture drawing.
And with chalk I just sort
of establish a spine--
establish some primary
limbs and then went into it
with hand stitching
to find my way
and built this sort of--
the imagery back up again.
And what interests me is that
we are talking about the largest
known structure in the cosmos--
this great expansive space.
But these feel so
connected in many ways
to that first quilt I showed
you-- that self-portrait.
But these are very
connected to the body
certainly through the active
hand stitching and that gesture
drawing in the
proportion of the works.
And-- but this finding--
this contemporary finding
from only a few years ago
still uses Henrietta
Leavitt's foundational work
as a tool to build
this finding from.
So several of these
works from this series
are included in the
gallery next door
as kind of demonstrating
the farthest reach
of that arm of her findings--
and yet again the bridging
another expansive time
with this exhibition.
And then the final work
I'll talk about tonight
is the drawing.
I-- as we call
it-- the drawing--
I decided to draw a positive
and negative plate of the Orion
Nebula.
And an impetus
behind this drawing
was to respect these objects,
these plates as objects
that have carried a
story through time.
And that is what I
believe objects can do
is carry a story.
Just as quilts have carried
often a story from generation
to generation to
generation through time,
these plates have carried
many layers of the story.
There is the technology itself--
that the dry plate photography.
Then the fact that this
plate was-- this glass
was shipped to Peru, where
somewhat miraculously Harvard
had established an
observatory in the 1890s.
It captured the starlight from
the sky on this date in 1897.
And then that plate traveled
around the tip of South America
back to Cambridge where these
women spent time looking.
And I do-- in the presence of
these plates I keep looking
at Lindsay who is in
the center who I--
graciously hosted me so many
times at the observatory.
But in the presence
of these plates
I did feel the presence
of these women.
I felt that there is a
way that their presence is
embodied in these objects.
And then you know, the
fact of their archive--
that they are stored up the
hill here at the observatory
for more than 100 years--
that an archive is
its own kind of marvel.
So there's all these
layers to that story
that I feel are
told in the details
of the emotion in that border
as well as the stars themselves.
And part of-- one layer of that
story which Jennifer addresses
in her essay in
our publication is
that because these plates
are the oldest and most
comprehensive record
of the night sky,
they hold great historical
astronomical value.
And so they're being digitized.
And that digitization process
includes scanning the plates.
And then if there
are any markings
on the plates from
the Harvard computers,
those markings are wiped clean.
And then the plate is
rescanned for a sort
of more cleaner, purer view
of the astronomical data.
And something is gained.
But certainly something
is lost in that process.
And Jennifer speaks
eloquently in her essay
to that sort of
urgency of holding
the space open for the story
of these women to be told.
And so I wanted to sort
of in making this drawing
sort of pay respect to the hours
spent looking by these women.
And I actually hadn't made a
pencil drawing as an artist
ever.
I hadn't made a pencil
drawing in 20 years.
So I didn't even know if I
could really pull it off.
But I just figured I would
just begin and find my way.
And I started by drawing
a grid onto the paper
just as Henrietta Leavitt
often superimposed
a grid over her plates
to help orient herself.
And then I just began.
And star by star--
as you see the grid slowly
forming and disappearing--
star by star I found my way.
And I knew that--
I knew it was a
large undertaking
to try to make this drawing.
I don't think I realized quite
how large an undertaking.
So this drawing
actually took me longer
to make than the stitch
dipped it took me
to sew, because every
time I picked up
my pencil it was like I
had to start all over again
and refind my way back in.
But in that process
and in mirroring
the process of Leavitt--
the active looking,
the active observing--
I found that I wanted
to pay attention,
that these stars
held my attention.
And it was actually a joy to
pay attention-- that every day I
walked into my studio
through my studio door
into my studio I was
excited to be there.
So with that action I
returned to my question
of what meaning is
held in a single action
and what meaning is built
with its repetition.
And I think part of the goal of
this exhibition and part of all
of you here tonight-- we can
hold together collectively
the meaning that
Henrietta Leavitt built.
But thinking about that
single action-- what meaning
is held there in my attention
being captured by these stars
I think about Henrietta
Leavitt's life.
And very little correspondence
remains from her life.
There's very little
known about her life.
But what from I could find
here in the Harvard archives
reinforce that indeed she was
deeply committed and engaged
and passionate about this work.
And I find great comfort
there, that in the specificity,
in the beauty, in the
uniqueness of that single action
there is meaning.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
We've got about 10 minutes, a
little longer for discussion.
Thank you.
That was a fantastic talk.
You already answered
most of the questions
I was planning to ask you.
- But I said it so fast.
[LAUGHTER]
We have to review some of it.
- I guess I'd like to
start by asking you
a little bit about your process.
One of the things that's been
striking to me in learning
about your work is the
way you have really
taken advantage of-- you've
learned about and absorbed
so many of the massive
technological developments
that have happened in
astronomy since the time
that Henrietta
Leavitt was working.
Those are part of your
work in the way you
use data and the way
you use visualization.
There have also been major
developments in sewing,
for example, say, the
industrial sewing machine.
And I wanted to ask you about
why, given these developments,
you choose to sew
your quilts by hand?
Every one of those
stitches is hand stitched.
You could just send a
digital file off and have
these quilts made industrially.
And they-- that would
be a lot faster.
That's for sure.
But you choose not to.
You choose to take
this intensive big data
information from the
world of astronomy
and turn it into the hand.
And I wonder if you could
just talk a little bit
about how and why you do that.
- Sure.
Well in one basic way hand--
when you hand stitch, you--
and I do this rocking
motion, because that's
the rocking motion that
you do when you stitch.
You sort of stack these
stitches onto a needle
and then pull it through.
You have a single line of
thread, whereas with a machine
you have these two
threads that interlock.
And you create a solid line.
But with that hand stitching
you have this dotted line.
And I've talked to you before
about this sort of the--
I call it the uncertainty
of the stitch--
that there is this
way that there
is with the dotted
line an uncertainty.
So translating this data
into the dotted line sort of
activates it in
this different way.
But there's also a way that I--
just as I made my
way star by star
in the drawing that
finding my way sort of inch
by inch through this
terrain is an important part
of the process.
This idea of mapping and going
back to that elemental theme
in my work of sort of
navigating that space
between the familiar
and the unfamiliar--
that the pace of sewing and that
sort of navigating that space
is central to the work.
- So the stitch disappears--
like half the time
it disappears.
- Exactly.
Right.
Well 50% of the stitch
is on the underside.
Right.
Exactly.
- Great.
I wonder if you could talk a
little bit about your working
routine.
One of the things
that you've spoken
about in terms of
your admiration
for Henrietta Leavitt was her--
not just the intricacy of
her work and the noticing
but just the sheer stamina and
persistence of spending years
sitting at the observatory
looking at these plates.
And I wonder if you
could talk a little bit
about how your work--
how you see your work
relating to her work
in that way in terms of routine
and persistence perhaps.
- Yeah, well and
that is why I work--
that I have research
based work, because
for me going out and
living in these archives
and experiencing them and
then having this story--
that story carries
me through the work.
So if I just set
out and was sort of
like an endurance
artist of like,
I will just repeat this
gesture over and over
and over again, it would
feel like an empty gesture.
But-- and I know in some ways
it's like almost too heartfelt.
But I felt--
I mean I felt Henrietta Leavitt
like every step of the way
in this process.
And her story really carried
me through that work.
And then when I
asked that question--
like what meaning is held
in a single gesture--
I think for me it was really
central to my own practice--
like sometimes I
do feel ridiculous
that I spend these hours
and hours making this work
but realizing that there
was real joy in it.
I really locked in on
the sort of specificity--
that each of those
stars was so specific.
And each of the stitch that
you make is so specific,
and sort of diving into that and
embracing that specificity did
produce such satisfaction.
So there was this way learning
that Henrietta Leavitt died
before, you know, the impact of
her findings was truly known,
feeling such a sense of
loss, and then feeling
such encouragement that
she was so deeply satisfied
by the work.
And realizing that I, too,
feel that same satisfaction.
So it is genuine--
[LAUGHTER]
--in case you didn't notice.
- And that's another reason
that the machine stitch
wouldn't make sense as well.
So I wanted to ask you to talk
a little more about the drawing
and in particular about the--
your decision to depict both a
positive and a negative plate.
It would have been faster
and easier certainly
to choose one or the other.
But--
- Negative-- the negative
is easier to draw.
- Negative would be easiest.
No, exactly.
And I mean we both noted when we
visited the observatory house--
what's stunning
and defamiliarizing
about the plates
is that you expect
to go see a bunch of images of
the black sky with white stars
on it.
But for the most part it's
this milky surface with dots
that look very much
like a graphite drawing
in the first place.
But Leavitt used
the juxtaposition
of positive and
negative plates to help
her locate variable stars.
So she would put one
on top of the other.
And if a star had varied
between the two exposures,
you would see this
tiny misalignment
in the way the
light came through.
So she's using positive
and negative in a way
to locate certain
kinds of stars.
And I wonder if you could
just talk more about
how that relationship has--
what that has meant for
you both in the drawing
and in your work more generally.
The quilts too strike me
as being very much invested
in this very-- this kind of
high contrast relationship
between dark and light as well.
- Right.
Well absolutely
the initial spark
was that the positive
and negative plates
were so relevant to Leavitt's
own process of finding--
identifying these
variable stars.
And the Orion
Nebula, which I drew
was the first place you
looked for those stars and is
a birthplace of the stars.
But I'll leave that to
Alyssa over there and Joel.
So yes, but so there was this
like scientific connection.
But then I realized
in my work so often I
set up these poles of sort of
positive and negative, life
and death and the diptych.
I've touched on these you know
public and private, subjective
and objective that I so often--
that I was doing it
through each body of work.
I was like, oh, that one
was about black and white.
And this one-- you know, so
that I set up these poles.
And then I navigate
the space in between.
So with these positive and
negatives in some ways,
it is an inverse.
It is a flip relationship.
But in drawing the stars,
especially in those middle
range stars how you perceive
a middle range star--
so you know a sort of star
that's not bright and not tiny
but those middle range stars--
really appeared so differently
on the positive plates
and appeared almost as different
stars in the negative so that
to me this sort of gray
area of-- or where there's
these touch points
that no longer polarize
the two extremes was
an interesting terrain
to navigate.
- I'm curious
about your decision
to move into biography
for this project
and what that means for
you in terms of your work
maybe going forward as well.
In your past work you
have had some moments
of self-portraiture.
Portraiture has been part
of your work in the past.
You've also worked with enormous
cultural and historical events
that haven't always
been tied cleanly
to the life of a single person.
But here you're really working
on a biographical level
for perhaps the
first time, at least
in such a sustained
way in your work.
How has that-- how
has-- how do you
see this over the span of
your own work than the way
you think about time?
- I was like wasn't expecting
the kicker at the end.
[LAUGHTER]
- That was just a possible
example of something
you might say.
- Well I was-- what
I was laughing--
what I was thinking about
when we were putting together
the book that Henrietta
Leavitt's logbook page is
on the cover.
And I was remembering when
we were putting together
the book that I was just so
enamored of her life and so--
I mean deeply respectful of
her life and accomplishments
that it was like Leavitt,
Leavitt, Leavitt.
And then eventually
I was like, oh, wait.
Actually I should be
in this book somewhere.
I forget-- so there
was a way that
like that was just so enjoyable
really working specifically
on her story and
her life and wanting
to carry that story forward
that it felt no longer about me.
But I-- what you just made
me realize that-- and yes,
in some ways this body of work
has had that unique angle.
But I realized all of my
bodies of work were like that.
So in that series
As the Stars Go By,
these historical moments
that I depicted--
I became so passionate about--
like the massacre
at Wounded Knee
was one event-- and sort of
really specifically telling
that story.
So in that exhibition
I actually had
these sort of epic summaries
of the events that occurred.
And that became
part of the piece.
So in a lot of ways
it was a return
to that using
quilts as a vehicle
to carry a story through time
so really embracing and leaning
into the story behind the work.
So in that way this exhibition
only reinforced that urge.
And then you added
time at the end there.
And I was like, oh.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm like going to have to
come back to that somehow.
- Well it does seem that all--
each of the star
quilts, for example,
usually depict a few hours
in the sky as the stars
move across the sky.
Of course, it's actually
the Earth that's
moving and not the stars.
I just wanted to make it
clear that I recognize--
[LAUGHTER]
--that I, in fact,
did know that.
Yeah, we've got that.
Anyway so you have these
multiple hour spans.
But the quilts also have
a really strongly locative
quality to them.
If you go into the
gallery, you'll
see that the birth panel
and the death panel--
one's over Lancaster,
Massachusetts.
And one's over Cambridge.
And they're taken at, of
course, different times
and also from different
points on the Earth.
And the arc of the stars has
a slightly different radius
to it.
So you really get a
sense looking at these
that you're looking not
just at a span of time,
but a specific point in space.
And it just strikes
me that that's
part of what's so powerful
about this exhibition
and these works, is that despite
the cosmic vision of the quilts
and the sort of epic
histories that they discuss,
it always does come down, almost
as in a perspectival system,
down to a single
body experiencing
these cosmic events.
So--
- Well said.
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
- Yeah.
- That's why we
make a good team.
I have one more question.
And then let's go
look at the work.
We've talked so much about the
relationship between your work
and astronomy or quilting--
all these other disciplinary
fields.
But you're also an artist.
And your work sits in a field
of art history as well--
a certain march of modern
and contemporary art.
And I wonder if you'd
like to say anything
about how your work fits
into the history of art.
We, for example, have
talked a little bit
about the way your quilts call
up Frank Stella's black stripe
paintings.
But there are
multiple other ways
in terms of minimalism,
conceptual art that one
could talk art historically
about this work.
And I just thought I'd
give you an opportunity
to say whatever
you wanted to say.
- That is definitely your job.
You're the art historian.
[LAUGHTER]
But OK.
I'll give it a shot.
- I just take my cues from you.
So--
- Well I think my-- you know,
I've been working with this
medium of quilt--
quilts is primarily my meaning.
This drawing is as I told you
I kind of out of left field.
So I sort of have--
I don't think it's a
perfect term but working
with this idea of
conceptual craft.
And the contemporary
art world is
more sort of encompassing
and embracing of that.
But like I've been around
it for a little while now.
And that-- it was a tough
road to sort of navigate down.
So for me it was really locating
myself deeply in objects.
As I said, I do feel
like these objects
can sort of carry this story
but really coming at it
from a conceptual practice.
So I really identify more
as a conceptual artist
in that it's research based.
But it is really the idea
that drives the idea forward.
And the more I can
step out of the way--
I mean I love the star
calculation software,
because I'm like you're telling
me what these arcs will be.
And so they are a drawn line
but as prescribed by the system.
And so for me it's really
marrying that story--
you know, the idea of a
story with conceptual art
that I've said
this before that I
feel like story gets a bad rap.
Or it feels very quaint
or very gendered.
And conceptual art has a certain
sort of appeal and sexiness
behind it.
And I was like, hey, I want some
of that-- that conceptual art
really is just a story
that drives the work.
And so I am leaning
into that story.
- Maybe you should
be an art historian.
[LAUGHTER] That's very good.
OK.
We are not going to have
an audience Q&A. That
is what the opening is for.
So with a reminder to
check onviewatradcliffe.org
for the many events
that will be happening
in the gallery going forward
over the next couple months.
I will release us all
to go see the work.
And please join me in thanking
Anna again for her wonderful--
[APPLAUSE]
--talk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]